well first went the record stores then
crowds thinned down at the library and I
have to wonder if physical classrooms
could become another casualty of the
Internet age well if Khan Academy is any
indication the old schoolhouse will
survive but the way kids spend their
time inside it could change forever so
why are millions logging on to get
lessons from one man could your kids
benefit my co-anchor Terry Moran went to
find out no matter how old you are you
can probably still remember what the
bells sounded like at your school you
can still remember pushing your way
through the hallways to your next class
or the minute hand on the clock in your
math class that you swore ran slower
than every other clock in the building
but that was then this is now eight
meters and the same thing along the side
welcome to the Khan Academy online
learning on steroids a One World
schoolhouse that is skyrocketing
popularity sparking controversy and
fundamentally challenging the very
notion of education in the 21st century
what we're tackling right now is the
learning side how can we democratize the
information the knowledge so that anyone
can get to whatever level they want to
Sal Khan founded the Khan Academy kind
of by accident more on that in a minute
first the sheer scale of this thing
seven million students around the world
are attending the Khan Academy online
every month and that number is growing
by 400% per year the thousands of
lessons everything from algebra to
medieval history to the fiscal cliff
they've been viewed more than 200
million times and all for free are you
out to dismantle our educational system
I'm not an education radical a lot of
what I'm doing and we're doing is really
bringing back very very old ideas that
have been proven but somehow got lost in
the fray Sal Khan is an unlikely
education reformer
he's a former hedge fund analyst MIT
undergrad Harvard MBA who just really
stumbled upon his revolution when he
tried to help a young cousin with her
algebra homework back in 2000
full-colour I started tutoring remotely
I was in Boston she was in your
and after that I start tutoring other
family members and eventually put the
stuff on YouTube in a few weeks Khan
noticed that this stuff he was making
for his relatives was going viral the
requests from strangers for more more
more anti biotics visually they aren't
the kind of videos you'd expect to go
viral they're more of a virtual
blackboard but they work and education
reformers all over the world have
noticed including some heavy hitters
there's a new website that I've just
been using with my kids recently called
Khan Academy ka Chan just one guy doing
some unbelievable 15-minute tutorials
Bill Gates did more than look at the
Khan Academy videos he helped to
bankroll the project so in 2009 Khan
finally quit his day job and partnered
with the Gates Foundation and Google to
form the Khan Academy here's how it
works
students watch the videos and then work
on a problem set based on the lesson on
the website if you pass you move on to
the next lesson if it looks like you
don't understand a concept the site
takes you back through what you are
missing the goal is not to replace the
traditional classroom the goal is to
liberate the idea of students being
grouped in age-based cohorts and then
going at a set pace this is the school
that we all kind of grew up in this is
actually not the way students were
educated for most of history instead
Khan and his allies see classrooms
throbbing with creative activity spurred
by the fact that kids will have already
engaged the subject matter through the
online lessons what is your ideal
classroom look like it won't be a bunch
of chairs all positions looking at
someone in the front of the classroom
it'll be a much more collaborative space
it's not one piece fits all anymore and
the the teacher will be doing focused
interventions with them they'll be
mentoring them they'll be inspiring them
they won't be lecturing at them about 25
to 30 schools most of them based around
Silicon Valley have started implementing
the Khan Academy as a pilot program
exploring how it might change teaching
and learning there are plenty of critics
but one big group of supporters the
single biggest thing that happened and
it wasn't obvious to us at first the
teachers and the the principal told us
is that the students started to take
ownership of their learning they started
to not say hey I'm passive tell me what
to do next they started to say this
these are my goals I'm going to seek out
the information teacher you're my coach
you're my mentor help me do it
don't they're already online maybe at
least in some ways that's where their
classrooms can be too and cons book the
one world schoolhouse is in stores now
thanks to Terry